oh my god
oh my god hang on let's just hold
everyone stop
wagon sports fans sng fandom
phantom mandem yeah g so
same old like subscribe to this video if
you're
checking on youtube
uh youtube audio listeners make sure you
subscribe
and jump on that this is that this is
the the the patreon plug
that's just it's haircut so yeah
this patreon this is the thing that i i
forgot to mention a while ago yeah hit
me
so obviously for patreon
grant admission 1k thank you so much
love
if you want that raw rule if you want
that too that's true if you don't give a
damn about mission 1k
if you're like i don't care about
japanese man and i'm content with one
episode a week yeah
if you won that anything now dead
patreon fam
if you want that raw that nasty
that's where patreon's at they're back
they're back raw dog
that's that's brav that's that's
unedited
unfiltered that that nasty
that's that's patreon for you so yeah
head over there that one complaint this
is the thing this is
this is the funny thing that you men
don't get the one complaint we got not
even a complaint
the one suggestion we get all the time
one suggestion we go all the time oh god
yeah
get better one better one get better on
these man didn't know
ah this is cute this is actually cute
this man didn't know there's been a
bella episode on patreon from
the jump from jump from
jump there's been a bella patreon i'm
sure from last year
yes fam it was one of the first episodes
we did yeah
anyway so yeah guys jump on link in the
description link should be popping up on
your screen
as uh three pound a month if you want to
upgrade the thing you can but yeah we
we appreciate contributions enjoy the
bonus episodes yeah let us know what you
think
but without further ado sir
do you have a fun fact today god i've
been on my animal things for a bit so
let me let me keep that up
um so well i've got two actually let me
do this another one
did you know that wait first of all a
multiple of octopus
what would you say plural octopus yeah
octopi that's what i would say no it's
actually octopuses
octopuses yeah that's not the fun fact
by the way who got lazy enough
what lazy ass dudes was i just call them
octopuses
really that is slack
fantasy slack octopuses
wait let me double check because i sure
fab this is when people are gonna be
like are you sure cause
hold on hold on hold on oh this is gonna
be embarrassing for you fam
please say that's right
yeah octopuses yes octopuses that's wild
to me but a lot of people obviously
because there's a lot more
a lot more people think it sounds better
as occupied there's a
is it occupying yeah people are taking
sides
yeah they said damn the dictionary where
it is octopuses anyway
sorry um did you know that octopuses are
oct or octopi for you
people that are the new age yeah do you
know that octopus
octopuses have around 2 000 suckers
and all of them and they use them
individually
they use suckers individually like you
know the suckers they've got yeah
they're little circles too
on average 2000 and they use them
individually like fingers
i was just about to say imagine having
two thousand fingers
how is that possible fam i got this fact
because i watched a documentary on
netflix called
i think my octopus teach fam louis told
me to watch it i watched seven minutes
and i i couldn't do it fam he told me
it's
fantastic it's fantastic
fantastic i'm gonna have to give another
guy i couldn't be bothered for it
it's fantastic my man's voice was just
boring
it's because you automatically want to
hear david attenborough that's probably
the reason
maybe i don't know but just it's boring
because it's different it's very
different yeah
like if you if it was better you know
what it was it was bear artsy fartsy
i wanted details and he was bare like
you today he was just barely
gets there you said you watched seven
minutes yeah it's a great documentary
all right i'll give it another shot it's
a great documentary i'll give it
the other sorry to spoil it a little bit
because
anyway that's what we're doing yeah um
the second half of the
fun fact was that did you know that if
they get an arm severed off
it grows back i did excuse me i did not
know that
yeah like a chameleon thing that's what
they do for the tails that's mad
yeah bro octopuses are like i'm saying
it now
octopus an octopus is like the most and
apparently people say that their closest
thing to aliens
okay they're the closest thing to aliens
because they can just
do stuff do stuff here it doesn't make
sense like they can
you know when they camouflage yeah they
physically change their texture yeah so
they feel like a rock
yeah and then they're smooth again but
that doesn't make sense
that you see that happen in this
documentary really you see it happen
it blew my mind yeah that's what you
need to watch it the visuals are great
okay okay i will watch it i will watch
it i will watch it um
yeah bro an octopus is the most
fascinating creature this is why he
falls in love with it not in that
context but like
not in that context but like he falls in
love with the animal that species
because it's it's mind-boggling how
smart they are obviously you can't talk
to me can't communicate with it
but it's it's crazy they make a
connection bro
i've heard it's weird it's mind-blowing
they make a connection
okay you need to watch it you need to
watch it okay i'm here it's fantastic
it's a fantastic documentary all right
cool man i love and i love a documentary
so yeah gang that was my fun fact all
right g i'm here for it
right guys we've got a little special
event for you man today
oh god i forgot about it already a
special event for you man today so
the shot glasses are out it's a sip sip
thing
so we are going to do
a best friend quiz
so i'm gonna ask who had some questions
that he should know as my best friend
why are you why are you boying the thing
like that why are you adding fuel to the
fire
and if he doesn't know them he has to do
a sip sip you're making them go on your
side already
bro it's calm obviously coming back my
way
i know i know i'm going to skirt through
the ticket so it's mine
um so yeah are you ready fam yeah man
so i've got ten questions yeah i was
going to do a bonus thing actually but i
think i
locked it let's see
best friend quiz oh okay cool
oh i did do bonus questions guys i'm
nervous i'm nervous i don't know why
right number one yeah yeah what is the
name of my mum's
old dog that died do you know the
maddest thing
that was the one question i didn't want
you to ask me
i thought about that when you asked me
to ask to write some questions i was
thinking
i hope he hasn't got that question
because ah
i don't remember and the thing is
oh it's madder that's the first question
you asked me
because i remember that vividly yeah i
know you do you played with that dog g
you had a bond you don't even remember
her name he
bastard i was hoping you didn't ask me
that question
i'm after double back drink your ting
what are you doing
back no because i want to get out of
here okay yeah i won't tell you that
i know i've lost for now for the rules
all right
but i'm gonna need some help so if you
like give me like the first letter yeah
once we're all done yeah once we're all
done we'll go back and i'll let you know
the ones that
you want to know um i know i know it no
i'll help you now
if you want no no no no i like the fact
that we're going to go back to you all
right
i like that cool cool it gives it a bit
more i'll put a little uh
put like a color to it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
what a great question because i was
hoping that wasn't the question
enjoy
oh
cool man all right you ready yeah
oh god i'm probably gonna drink all
night right
what you know this is annoying you knew
it anyway but you knew this because we
coincidentally spoke about it today
okay what superman what no last night we
spoke about it when we were out for
dinner
what supermarket were we in when i got
caught cheating for the first time
and what was my reaction so two-part
question
even if we didn't talk about it
yesterday
i would never get that question wrong i
know i know i know
i would never get that question wrong if
that was the first question
i would have thought i'm breezing this
if the dog question was the bonus round
oh yeah i failed the whole thing oh fam
oh
anyway that's hilarious um we were in
sainsbury's obviously
yeah your reaction was you dropped the
basket
you held nothing came out and you said
mandem
i've got to go
he looked at his phone read a message
gasped
dropped a basket fell to the floor not
felt the floor like
accident was about to throw up is there
man now i've got to go
drop this basket and dipped just
dipped um i will never forget a
terrifying day of my
life most terrifying day of my life
fair play oh my god jesus christ i've
never felt
anything like it i've never heard
anything like it
i would never forget it bro it came
that text came out of nowhere oh that
takes came out of nowhere
oh straight to the point none of this
so where were you last thursday none of
that stuff straight to
the point cause i know everything i was
terrified
anyway okay cool that's sweet you'd be
number three where were we where were we
when we first discovered tequila sip sip
oh oh that's a great question we were in
now called boulevard we're in
neighborhood gang easy peasy
your boy hooked us up with the thing
welcome sam goff say for that
yeah man he's the reason why we do
tequila tips yeah man
cool this is interesting
what are the what are the names of all
three of my siblings
that was another question i wish you
didn't ask me because i know you've told
me about your younger brother and sister
so many times
but you hardly ever tell me their names
you know what's funny you've
actually asked me about them twice since
i've been here
yeah i know but i've intentionally not
mentioned their names and i thought that
and i said just in case this
[ __ ] asked me this question
because i've intentionally not said
their names obviously i know lawrence
because yeah i know him more of
reference but i'm gonna have to because
i'm
gonna have to sit because i don't
remember their names but i know
i knew you weren't gonna remember their
names awesome
[ __ ] awesome [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
was trying to be nice
say no more all right i've got a couple
more questions you got a couple more
write
[Laughter]
oh funny
all right let me drink my drink first
while i get carried away yeah yeah my
now
yeah cool we'll double back to that as
well yeah yeah yeah put a
put a little thing on it so laurence you
know i've got you
yeah but the other two younger brother
the younger sister
oh it's fine it's all good in it
we hardly ever talk about them this is
true
yeah mum
how much pineapple is in there a lot oh
okay go oh that's blessed
i get concerned okay
juicy oh this you're you should not you
do
you do let me write a couple of
questions all right go and write your
things
[Laughter]
funny i'm confident but i'm not
i'm really not
all right that's two questions yeah
three more and i'll probably do a bonus
all right what did the easy ones what
nickname why would you do easy ones well
not even easy ones just because i
couldn't i didn't know what context of
what
you've given me scenarios yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm just giving you a question
i know i know what i mean yeah
so right what nickname did my school
friends have for me
pay yeah yeah wasteman
um so for context guys uh patty
short for patrick so my mom's irish
um so i'm half irish and my middle name
is patrick
so laugh it up
i hate women i hate my middle name i
hate it
but it is what is my granddad's name so
con
right oh okay cool um
we also kind of spoke about this since
i've been up here which is a bit
annoying but
you'd know it anyway okay okay so
two shots i have all sports
yeah what sport do i have
the most amount of talent in but enjoy
the least
the most amount of talent in so what am
i most talented in
but don't enjoy doing it as much as
other sports
there's probably only two and there's
only two i'm thinking of at the moment
you have to pick one
obviously i know that i know that
because when you've when you when you
first started i thought you're going to
say
what's the most but i have more
accolades in
um say the question again
so what sport am i most talented in yeah
but enjoy the least see this this
baffles me because i don't
it's out of two things i don't think you
don't i don't think you enjoy this one
the least
but i believe you have the most talent
in this because i don't know you as much
as
the sport you used to play when i first
met you do you know what i mean you
already know the two sports i'm thinking
of yes
so i don't know i don't know whether you
don't enjoy that
do you know what i mean i choose because
i choose
but you see where i'm coming from that's
exactly where you're coming from [ __ ]
shoes
because i don't know whether you okay
for context
the two options are that i personally
believe
are basketball and boxing basketball is
the one that i
know him to love the most but i don't
know whether i don't feel like he enjoys
the lease
but boxing is what he used to do around
the time i first met him
and i would never have any context to
know whether
he enjoys that at least and that's the
one i believe he has
a lot of accolades in because i've seen
it um
so yeah i feel like that's that's that's
i feel that's breaking the rules because
i don't know but i would go for
i'm gonna stick with my guts and hope
you wouldn't hate playing basketball so
i'm saying boxing
correct yes correct correct
well done son well done i'm stuck with
my gun
so yeah boxing was the one for me bad
trophies but
it's not something yeah it's not
something boxing was something
that i started can i cut you off yeah i
hope for the fans it just shows how much
i know you by the way yeah of course
we're like
you're doing well that's all right
because i've sipped twice but that was a
i made up for that i didn't anyway so
yeah boxing was something
um that i started when i was about
13 14. before i knew him yeah see i know
these things
um and carried on until
i was still doing it when we met right
yeah when we met yeah
carried on until i was about 19 probably
stopped 19.
i know this is 20. yeah there you go um
and yeah bear tournament spare fights
trophies a lot but it wasn't something i
ever
really enjoyed so something that i did
because i was good at it
early yeah and a couple of my boys were
doing it
and i was like sick who doesn't want to
do that yeah so i did it
obviously liked it but once i got to the
point where i was just doing fights all
the time
yeah running waking up early
dieting all this stuff i was just like
this is not fun and it's not a team
sport
so you just it's so low there's no
engagement yeah yeah i'm
not trying to fight you cuz yeah it's
not it's not pleasant it's
true i don't want to be there it's too
intimidating
fam it's a lot for these accolades it's
a lot for a teenage boy
you're walking in the ring bear man are
bowing because obviously you have to go
to other people's venues in it
so you're going to if i have if i have a
fight in
hertfordshire or the man there that a
lot of the time the guy i'm going to
fight is from hartfordshire [ __ ]
so you go in there bare bowing i'm 14
femme
don't boo me and then baboo in from
his family's there everything and then
we gotta fight for our lives
trying to knock each other out it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ]
it's it's great the highs are high and
the lows are low yeah i bet and there's
no one else to lean on because it's just
you in there yeah
oh wow so yeah i loved the basketball
yeah but i was
much better at boxing unfortunately
unfortunately see it just shows so much
you did well on that one gee well done
um
okay cool oh god no this is easy you got
this one okay
what sport did we always
okay what sport would it be
yeah i didn't even finish the question
finish the sentence for these people
what sport would we always rent out the
uni sports hall to play
table tennis table tennis ping pong me
and him had
wars on the table tennis cars we went
for it it was [ __ ] sick i fully
redeemed myself people have forgotten
about them two shots
yeah bro we're flying through these boys
i'm on number eight now i swear yeah i
thought we're like five percent
oh wow um let me just make sure
are you sure yeah
oh wow okay so i've gotten six right six
right too wrong oh wow
okay i'm not i'm not all right cause
disappointed in what city
oh okay oh god in what city do we both
agree we had the best
night of our lives
over bright on i hope i'm right
i'm trying to think of this leads okay
leads fan gang gang gang gang gang gang
gang gang
leads cars that's the first thing i
thought but then i started to doubt
myself
so let me just tell these man about
leads hate them the [ __ ] people i'll
pay these man the picture so
i was going to say i want a drink but
it's not losing someone have another
drink i'm going to have a different
drink
that's fine so um
me and this guy this guy was working in
leeds on a
little sabbatical let me let me give you
the back context as to why he came out
i'm gonna have a drink while you do it
yeah um so i back at that time i was
working in london
and i worked for a company obviously i
was in hospitality so i was
not obviously but i was a manager for a
company a restaurant
and they had a branch in leeds
and they were launching like the new
they rebranded
the menu and the brand itself what do
you want oh pineapple
they rebranded the brand itself and the
first initial launch was in leeds
because they had about seven or eight
different
um venues
so i went to help out with that and went
to learn
i was there for two weeks and then i
worked i [ __ ] hated it as well no i
loved it i loved the experience but i
worked
13 days out of the 14. no i suppose
obviously i had two days off that's a
lie i had two days off
no yeah i think i already had two days
i think i only had 14 i think i only had
two days off i don't think i worked 14
days because i think i got there on
the sunday i think i was in leeds for 14
days but i worked for 12 something like
that
or 13 something like that so i got there
on the sunday obviously didn't work that
day
just found out where it was etc and then
um went there on the monday to start my
day or whatever i'll start my shift
and i think i worked i think i had two
days off
one of those days i was meant to go and
see vixx our mutual friend
um because she was in manny she was
already up in money at that time
um but i got food poisoning from a
chinese that i bought earlier that day
oh because obviously i'm staying in a
telly
i didn't really know at least that while
i was thought might as well order some
food i got my laptop i'm going to chill
in all day
and then i was going to go see her got
food poisoning wasted the whole day
and then my other day off was when you
came up no it wasn't
yeah it was no oh no it wasn't a day off
because i got there when you finished
about 10.
it wasn't a day you had worked the very
next day so i must have only had one day
off
that day off was my sick day ah
that's horrible but yeah that was the
back context he would not give you the
context was the best night
he's up in leeds on his two-week stint
messaged me coincidentally i had nothing
going on that night when usually i would
be busy
the message would be like yo what are
you doing tonight and i was like
chilling fam saturday night chilling
not doing nothing and i think
i was living with my mum at the time
yeah i think so and i just pulled up to
my mom's house
ready to go in and relax yeah because
this was probably
seven eight o'clock at night yeah and
you were like yo
i'm in leeds um i'm trying to go out
tonight
what are you saying do you want to just
do like a road trip thing yeah i was
like
hell yes ran inside pack my bag quick
chucked in the car i was like mom i'm
out dipped up to leads
and that was like it's like a two and a
half hour drive for me and you were like
cool
come to my work i'll give you the hotel
key go get changed et cetera et cetera
et cetera
i was giggy went in there showered
dressed changed aftertaste
smelling nice so you come back
we catch up we have a few drinks in the
hotel yeah
and then we go out to where he was
working right yeah i had a few drinks
there yeah when you guys were closing
shop
yeah had a few drinks they had a few
laughs and then we were walking down the
road and
thinking cool what's going on tonight
like what's going on tonight
so get out there and then um yeah we get
out and we're walking down the street
and then obviously we had a few drinks
in our system now and we both looked at
each other
and just randomly thought like i'd love
to go to sleep tonight
i'd love to go to a street tonight but
obviously we have no idea where anything
yeah yeah this is lee's we've got no
contacts got no contacts
i was there for two weeks but i was just
working i wasn't going out yeah so we
it was kind of like a passing thought
yeah we thought we're not going to be
able to find just a random strip
so let's just leave it out of nowhere
like guy just appears god sent him
himself he just appeared out of the mist
and was like yo you met he was a bit
shady i'm not gonna lie
and he was like yo you meant looking for
a strip club tonight i was like
yo yes yes he said oh there's a new
thing just open up
doing a bargain tonight entry
a drink and a dog for 10
pounds sterling it was an opportunity we
couldn't miss
and i was thinking these girls are gonna
be disgusting
disgraceful entry alone is usually ten
pounds
the least i've ever paid just to get in
the door is ten pounds minimum so i'm
already thinking
okay this is the drink
this can't be right this can't be right
we're here we're here
we're never going to do it again i'm
open-minded just say yes ugly girls need
to get paid too yeah just right
all right cool man let's go have a good
time so we went in there the girls
were not bad at all
not bad at all very polite
very polite so
yeah anyway we had our drink we had a
dance had a nice conversation
yeah and we left giddy happy like yeah
yeah let's have a good time so we're
going out
um i remember i'm drunk at this point
i remember we go trying to get into this
club and i was wearing
trainers i was wearing trainers
and then i said trainers they were in
black vans like i used to always wear
black
ways and they're basically shoes yeah so
how's that they can get me in anywhere
yeah they
fam they're the go-to if you want
comfortable footwear on a night out and
you don't want to wear
clarks daddy um
you wear comfortable black vans so i
wouldn't
donate the door was like not tonight cuz
not in them
so we sprinted to them because i've
packed wait oh i sprinted
he sprayed it back to the hotel but i
was happy in a weird kitty way
you had shoes back you ran with joy i
ran miles
you ever feel so drunk that you feel
like you can run forever yep
that's what i was doing that it was cold
at night as well and then
so yeah run run run run ran back to the
hotel got my shoes on run run run run
i remember just before we went in there
was a bit of a queue so we're like cool
let's go into this bar have another
drink yeah so went in there now
and there were two things sitting
together they were
piff banging p-i-f banging
things and we were like damn these guys
are nice
so anyway saw that had a drink back to
where
my man wouldn't let me in and we're like
cool let's have a good time we get in
and the club's
popping popping i think we go do we go
downstairs it's weird
yeah yeah he's got a weird name the
butter can remember
the thing's called like back alley
satellite yeah
i remember that night bear tlc every
team found out i was gassed
drinking drinking drinking laughing
laughing laughing dancing dancing
dancing dancing having the sickest time
now lo and behold i'm feeling a little
bit
saucy i've got liquor in my system i
feel like
saucy and loose and i'm like
these two things the buffings from the
bar are just walking around as a pair
lipsync guys as a three thing
and i'm thinking with my obviously the
younger me is a nastier james
i'm thinking yo i've always wanted a
three-way lips yeah
so they make their way over to me and
i'm like guys
yo let me say it what's this lipstick
thing
bear tongue taking this girl around
tonight
what's this fever what's going on
and they lift your boy
just
[Laughter]
about 30 seconds of just one nice so i'm
like gang fam
come back i'm beaming in like a chest
[ __ ]
[ __ ] like grinch on christmas bro
so that was that finish off the night
probably
spoke to a few more things that night as
well that's what this was i was in my
[ __ ] face
um and then yeah bro it's just it was
just a fantastic night
we laughed the night away drank and
danced and then
yeah it was the best night ever went
back to the hotel we slept for about 14
hours straight
and this is i know i was drunk because i
was stuck
in the same position the whole night i
didn't move the whole night and usually
i roll in my sleep
that's when i was wasted i collapsed and
i woke up and i clearly been laying on
this side
my hip was destroyed
destroyed and you had to drive back home
it was like a two and a half hour drive
back home i had to work for 10 hours
that day i was on the clothes i remember
i was on the two clothes i woke up we
woke up at like 10 to 1.
bro yes we woke up you you literally had
to sprint to get ready and go straight
to work
i wouldn't i would have quit on the spot
it was the worst day no we went for food
we
didn't know no we didn't straight from
the hotel to your work i remember
no mothers mothers mothers mothers we
went for food
and i started i think i started at three
and we woke up at one we had time to eat
we went in we ate and i started work
that day i remember
i was sure mother's life no no no no oh
you ate i remember you ate because you
said you were gonna get a roast yeah
yeah you did you
said that you were there though no i
didn't know i think no i went straight
home i promise i know i ate though yeah
i know you ate because i remember you
kept saying i'm going to get the roast
i'm getting a rice i'm getting rice okay
one million percent
with the hangover that i have there's no
whales okay
i remember you running across to go to
the car park yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i remember eating it yeah yeah
yeah
i dipped [ __ ] i was like years ago it
was years ago it was like five six years
ago maybe
maybe even longer probably yeah it was
great though yeah it was a great time
sick time bro so yeah that was that was
one of the
if not the best night i've ever had in
my life it's the great best night
i ever had in my life that that was such
a nice story that i forgot we were even
doing the best
quiz true i thought i thought we'd just
talk about leads true
cool number nine oh i'm back to the
[ __ ] electric chair
sentence do i hate you saying before we
go out out
i'm so [ __ ] tired
this guy's always tired from
when the good vibes are rolling this guy
loves to kill
the [ __ ] mood but am i not always
active when i'm out
when we're active once we get out but
from we'll be there vibing music's
playing
a few sip sips in the thing just locked
off the podcast ready to go and i'm like
yo
i haven't been out in a minute obviously
this is pre-corona yeah i haven't been
out i'm ready to get loose
and you're like james i'm [ __ ] tired
i'm so [ __ ] tired and i'm like what
are you doing to me
why are you doing this bro for god's
sake but yes oh that's exactly it
um number 10. oh [ __ ] i'm what
i've got seven i'm seven for nine now
okay yeah right
what imaginary pet name did you steal
from me
to use on your own thing
i'm eight for ten now baby soft skin
waste man baby soft skin
so baby soft skin is a phrase he used to
call sweet ones
before sweet ones was a ting he would
say baby soft skin and i remember one
time
i was seeing a ting oh no i don't think
i was seeing her at that time you
weren't
i would definitely haven't seen my
senpai fancy this girl at this time
um and i knew she liked me and i
messaged her one time and i called her
baby soft skin and i remember telling
james
yo gee by the way you sat me down like a
parent family i couldn't need to tell
you i need to tell you something i
called
i called home girl over here baby soft
skin at your face
i my jaw hit the floor i felt so
betrayed
that's so betrayed that's so funny
bonuses so there's one actually it's one
bonus oh god so
double or nothing on the bonus
okay yeah yeah cool yeah [ __ ] it out so
you have to answer three questions but
there were
all basically the same thing okay so one
what's my so it's all about alcoholic
beverages yeah i should know some
alcoholic beverages it's not alcohol
beverages
drinks okay just drinks okay what's my
favorite drink
alcoholic and on non-alcoholic my
favorite drink period
chili and coke that's a favorite or
monster
i thought you meant you said alcohol i
said alcoholic and non-alcoholic
okay monster monster cool one out of
three okay
what's my favorite spirit with a mixer
oh jd and coke
gang and what's my this is this is the
good one this is the clincher
think carefully what's my favorite
cocktail
i think i know i actually think i know
where it is go on actually it's in
australasia
go on it's australasia oh what's it
called
it's the long one with the the cause i
remember you saying use the backhand you
said it's my favorite cocktail ever
um do you remember you remember what
it's called wow of course
wow but i'm right you know i'm right
from what i'm saying say what it's
called fam i asked you what my favorite
content is you told me
oh wow and i used to work that way there
for two years and i can't remember what
his drink's called
[ __ ]
uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you must have googled this or something
how can i google it for the menu fam i
don't know
it's not been on the menu for years they
took it off the menu and you used to
have to order it for me
park why did i remember all right i'll
give you one clue
okay cause i know it looks i just can't
remember what it's called
so what do you call food that's hot
that's like well like spicy hot
spice oh spice
you can give up if you want to give up
my dice
it's not spice bottled mojito
there's something else spice
park do you want me to tell you
i'm sure it's the one with like the
lemongrass thing or like the ginger
garnish you can just tell me i can't
know what it's called spiceman in the
sling
spiced vanilla sling i was never gonna
get it
i was never gonna get i know that's your
favorite drink
[ __ ] you know what my favorite cocktail
right now yeah as a bridge and i'm going
to let you off that thing
because you knew what it was i knew it
was that just never was never cool
it's funny that the the three things you
got wrong were three name things
interesting anyway run run your tinker
no no no tell me oh are we gonna oh yeah
let's double back
double back and give me clues because i
feel like i remember them like your dog
one for example
so my dogs my mom's dead dog is called
sadie sadie yes
and my brother is called alex and my
sister called sophia you weren't ever
going to get it never get there
i saw your face you're like i was
definitely your eyes did not widen
anytime you just
i was never going to say it rings all
the bells alex and sophie i was never
going
so yeah g cool man you did well though
you did very well
thank you well done right run me this
thing let me smack this up
oh god my questions are
light work maybe not
i've only got seven questions so far
what was my first job
ever yeah oh you said this today
um you were like uh you weren't in the
kitchen
at your um at your uh boarding school
yeah that's fine right yes if i hadn't
said that today would you ever know
i would say blue ink
[Laughter]
if you answered that today i would have
not got it okay cool
one one out of ten um how old was i when
i lost my virginity
16 17 drink and i thought mine was easy
i'm not gonna lie to you i was tossing
between 16 and 17 but i knew you were in
sixth form
so i was toss it i was tossing between
it found perfect oh that's annoying
yes i feel so much better i feel so much
better
i feel so much better now because i've
got one yeah i feel so much better now
this one's an easy one i hope
this next one's an easy one
it's great in it let me put it back in
fantastic
i'm so happy we chose to do this
right right remember i said it's an easy
one yeah
when's my birthday
17th feb you shot yourself a little bit
though you know why it was because
my brothers is the third of feb and i
was so close to being outside of heaven
but then i knew that wasn't your
birthday fam oh my god yeah seventeen
for february i've got you do you shut
yourself up
all right what am i intolerant to
uh shellfish crustaceans all them things
and and
hang on mollusks
hang on let me hide them over myself let
me cover my
thoughts i was thinking what are you on
about let me gather my thoughts
mollusks you know why i know it's mostly
because you're the only human i've met
that says the word mollusk
[Laughter]
and you say it with such like eloquently
yeah yeah just blase oh yeah
no one's ever said mollusk but yeah cara
yeah got that got that
oh what year was i in when i had my
first kiss
um first kiss
hmm that's the play-doh about the
episode it is
you were in yeah fam because the thing
is i know the clip and in the clip you
even said i mean yeah
you said two years you were in year
nine yeah eight oh tossing between
are you know i feel so much better i
feel sick
i'm so happy you got two wrong now now
it depends on whether you get three
wrong
and i've only got seven questions
all right um
oh yeah sorry what i'm drinking yeah
are you moving closer in because this is
scraping
um
yeah um
so guys while my man's doing this let me
just riff of g man for a bit
i know um a lot of people obviously back
in the day when we did the first sip
sips they were wondering why i didn't
have a record deal
to be honest i'm wondering myself
so here's part 2b here's part two
i'm joking i would never i would never
even
know what to do i would never know where
to start i don't know how certain man
do that because that's a talent
but yeah man um
what are you guys saying what you up to
what are you feeling
i still haven't quit my job yet and
that's
that's up that's like
let's be honest that's your fault
that's your fault it's not mine
that's the damn truth i'm trying my best
i knew man a day in the comments like
yeah we love it we love it you don't
love it
because i'm still working and you're
like yeah we're going to be here when
you quit your job
help me help me i don't want
i don't want to be there for me
physically help me
but nah i'm playing like human are you
man alive okay i'm on nine but i can
i'll go through a couple and then
i'll probably think of another one um so
the last one
how many things how many do you think
we've done right now
six we're going to six now oh okay cool
and i've had how many shots two two two
out of five okay now
go on when was my sister married
what do you mean when what month what
month was your sister married yeah
that was a big moment in my life g
what kind of question is this okay can i
give you a should i give you a bit of
background
we were all in london at that time and
we all tried to link up
but i said i i wanted to
i was there no i think you were gonna
come to like i think you still came to
london
but you obviously linked the other man
but we're all meant to link up and i
think you
i've i don't know whether i can't
remember but anyway
yeah i remember but every man was
obviously rumors along the time i was in
london jay was in london obviously i was
in london but
i remember i remember and you were gonna
come down i remember
that one night away i remember couple
nights and
it was in i still remember the pictures
and this is hella sunny so i'm certain
it's a summer month
and i am going to say
that your sister
was wedded in the month
of the zodiac pertaining to
august
wrong what was it it was november 10th
so off
why are you making that face do you
recall certain things though
no but
i don't know fact oh
and i thought mine was easy that's a
hard
question i would never get your sister a
brother's name you knew i wasn't getting
that
my siblings names are easier than the
mother your sister was married
no i went there i've never met your
brother and sister
hey bro you you knew i was never going
to get that though that's the thing you
knew i was never going to get that
example oh there we go there so why are
you why are you mad
why are you mad are you mad b sip your
drink you're the worst best friend um
let me think of one more question why
you do your little sip
ah that's hilarious
oh i've got a good one all right
i'm not for crying out loud this is
torture
this is a great one okay
bloody nora cool um so that was
six when my sister married question
seven what's my nephew's name
and you know i mentioned
his name to you because when i say it
you're gonna be like oh i knew that
give me one more chance anyway i wasn't
taking that seriously obviously i know
that's that wasn't yourself
i can't remember phil i'm sorry what's
his name akeel
ah i did i've heard that once or twice
once or twice you've heard
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
i feel better
[Laughter]
i thought mine were easy
i'm terrible with names all my questions
were name wrong all the ones i got wrong
you said about
my names sadie alex sophia
and surprise vanilla sling i got them
all wrong
if they're not if it's not a nickname
what's that for four out of seven
so you drank three times you're still on
a good ratio yeah don't worry i won't be
doing another
question eight how long did i live in
nigeria
oh my god
oh my god hang on let's just hold
everyone stop
let's just think hang on
i say this all the time i say it on the
pod a lot
you do it's been a long day fam
it's 10 minutes past midnight i'm trying
my best
oh for [ __ ] sake um
you lived in nigeria for two years yes
oh oh god thing is i that's the first
thing that came to my head yeah
but i was so unsure yeah
oh christ almighty oh this is too much
to handle i've got a bonus question
okay but i'll say that after um question
10 cool
cool question nine
so you've gotten what five out of eight
uh question nine
i wonder i wonder if you i doubt you
remember this i don't
what year did i get fired from my first
job
you mean the first time you've been
fired
yeah yeah but oh yeah not from yeah from
the first yeah
what year was it from the first time i
got fired oh my god
you know i'm bad when the years bro okay
let me think
i think i know
oh or do i
i think you got fired
in 2015.
please say i got it right do you know
what i'm
for your sake i'm just gonna double
check on my linkedin because it's
probably still on there all right from
how long i was
i'm certain it was in 2015.
[Music]
i was thinking you were wrong as well it
was 2014.
yeah it was that long ago 2014
i was thinking it was 2014. [ __ ]
because i knew it was the year after i'd
met my ex
yeah [ __ ]
that's annoying because i did the maths
and everything
that's really [ __ ] annoying but you
were close
yeah whatever not close enough
i thought my questions were easy you
know i'm not good at years bro
every time you bring up a specific how
do you know yeah
reference points i guess
so what's that you're five for five no
what am i saying
you've drank that's four times now yeah
so you've gotten
six out of nine that makes no sense you
may have gotten five outlined
and you're wow you're probably going to
get this one wrong wow
you give me hard ones you're giving me
math spam i
gave you heartwarming remembering
scenarios
where were we where were we when this
magic happened
you're out here like you know that
person you've never met yeah what month
does she get married
[ __ ] sake go on which club do i always
say was the best gig i ever did as a dj
oh that you went there and it was me you
want the name
yeah [ __ ] sake
right just so the fans know that i am a
good friend
yeah this club was in coventry
it was opposite the coach station
it when you walk in it's really thin
like a hallway and then you walk into
the dance floor and it opens up
and the dj booth is like a like a
monolith
it's like your perfect ideal dj booth so
these men are thinking i'm a [ __ ] friend
i know exactly where it is
i just don't know what it's called
oh i'm going to throw
i'm just going to throw something out
there
it was called does it begin the letter c
yeah the club starts with club oh
club what were you gonna say i was gonna
say something like cliche or something
what is the well give me a clue please
please what does it begin with
s
[Laughter]
club
club what
the thing is well it's annoying because
why does your best set have to be in the
club we've been in
one time you never went there
i went there a couple times for we as a
as a group
didn't go there alone you went there
because people would book it for [ __ ]
yeah
and you knew people i didn't know people
um
club i don't know if
um club silk close club seven
club seven and it was felt like s e and
the v was a seven yeah i remember like
in the movie yeah
i remember now it's usually club seven i
remember that 17 yeah
son of a [ __ ] but i'll let you off
because you knew exactly what club was
the same way thank you spicy spices
i'll let you off thank you by this bonus
round
but this boat this bonus
but this bonus round ties into one of
the questions i've asked you
okay so the bonus round question is from
what year to what year did i live in
nigeria
like my school year oh okay cool i say
it all the time
you do from what year to what year yeah
this to you that
seven and eight you're winding me up
from your eight tier ten bro i say it
all the time you know i do
drink your drink and you had your first
lips in year eight yep
in nigeria yep see
that's your fault because yes you did
yes you did yes you did because i always
said
when i said the story i said me and my
sister were in boarding school her and
her boyfriend was stood up in front of
me
it was in nigeria there's no other way
there's no other place it would have
been we're important i always say we
went to boarding school
in nigeria you're right i know i know
i'm right
and that's what you're eighty year ten
yeah nigeria
classic so that would have been seven
or six because i'm gonna have to do two
because you can drink one
thank god you can join one because i'm a
nice guy thank you i'm a nice guy
this was your idea and i thought i was
going to fail
i thought i was going to fail i thought
you were going to give me heart warming
my first five questions were piss
what was my first job how did i remember
my birthday one man told him to when was
my first kiss i thought these were
minor questions
thing is the ones the first two that i
got wrong
yeah the first two that i got wrong
in my defense in the video when you were
talking about your first kiss
you said i'm liking your eight year nine
in the video you said that
i don't think so you're like i'm your
egg yeah i know i was in eight
the fans and i don't know that are you
sure you said yeah
you read the video back five you said
you went like this the hands the hands
were doing this yeah
yeah it could have been a different
story i'm not gonna lie to you that
you might be mixing two stories together
you might i might be talking about you
are you are you
talking about ignoring what i said
ignore myself when i first
asked out my first goal yeah i'm on
about a run awaiting
uh you're mixing two stories drink two
for that
drink two for that live drink two for
that
please live live drink two for that
mother's drink two for that i'ma have a
sweet while you do it drink food drink
two for that mothers
mothers mothers because
because when this started you said ah
it's a little ten question thing
man introduced a bonus round on a whim
no win or
hoping i'd fail so i can do to do um
double or nothing
praying i went back i know when i went
back out because the man did my watching
drink two for that [ __ ]
puss yo drink two for that
you deserve that
we might do a part to you guys that was
fun
for whom for me one nil i used one
[Laughter]
that as soon one you said one nil i was
not saying
don't put that back
the only thing though we'll take that
cartons of pineapple juice not pineapple
juice cartons of juice in general
yeah when you leave them especially once
they've been opened they ferment
so i must have left a carton of orange
juice or apple juice
number in my cupboard okay why they do
was in there for a couple months
never opened never opened it was one of
the things you know when you you're
buying drinks you're buying juice by a
few kinds you don't use some
so you keep them in the cupboard i think
i ain't got time for juice in my fridge
okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you found one day open a covered bear
juice pour it everywhere
mold everything the thing obviously you
know
when it's got the the pop and then the
seal
the whole thing burst out the thing
ferments in there and the bacteria foams
my assumption is you forgot the juice
was there oh yeah right because you said
you said a couple months like it was
normal today oh yeah i forgot i don't
think that's your fault i forgot i put
it in a different drawer
okay is that your second one
yeah you're such a liar
okay yeah yeah there's there's two for
that i'd already drank the first one
okay okay
is it
hmm you wrote me about your man tell me
no you sorry second one or not
might try to distract me so i can't come
certain it's the second one i'm sorry
this is the second one i'm not having
i'm telling you now i'm having a second
another one
right so granted you win the best prank
is
you won the best friend quiz one nil
foreign
so uh well done clap clap um
i'm gonna do a quick uh fan request
before we lock it because this one came
through
today no oh it says yesterday
oh yeah came through and i found it
hilarious
to us or to you to me
okay but maybe he's sending to everyone
i don't know okay
so my man said man
is it thick with two c's no okay what's
that
what's that
none of this hey james love the pod none
of that
man said i need some advice
out of the bar i need some advice right
man i said i really liked this girl
for like over a year but she's no she's
not good for me at all
being there we have got far but never
far
enough to be together and she's a bit of
a hoe
like she slept with a lot of my boys oh
wow um
oh no she slept with a lot of boys my
age sorry okay
she slept with a lot with my age she's
[ __ ] me over so many times and i know
i need to move on but she's the only
girl i want
and whenever i talk to other girls it's
not the same i said how can i
move on this [ __ ] is toxic
i've been there cuz i've been there
where this [ __ ] is
she's nothing but poison poison but you
can't get enough of it she's a heroine
you can't get enough [ __ ] she's pure
ah she's pure hell you can't
get enough fam i've been
how can i move on what question how
indeed
how did you move on just tell them how
you've done it
okay cool first of all who are you
talking about and then i can figure i
can think about it
b yeah oh yeah she was of course she was
no good who else but she wasn't a hoe
like it's not the same
thing she was clapped yeah she was crazy
crazy
but um yeah how did i move on
i moved on this is so actually this
sucks i moved on when we
left oh yeah yeah you had no choice i
had no choice but to move on
i remember you were so jealous when she
came to work for me at my spot
listen yeah listen you man don't know
about this yeah you might know about i
can't remember if you spoke about before
i was in love with this woman she was
the most beautiful girl at the time
i don't know what she looks like she was
like [ __ ] um
but at the time she was banging she was
[ __ ]
beautiful she was literally literally at
the time
for she was one of the penguins girls
i'd ever seen
she had a glow about her yeah bro i
remember the first time we saw her
i was walking in to the club that we
were going into
yeah we were walking into the hub yeah
walked in she was standing outside yeah
and i was like you man who oh
god green earth is that she's wearing a
red dress i still remember until now
and i was thinking jesus wet yeah this
thing is fire
anyway long story short obviously your
boy secured the thing
my god my guy obviously your boy secured
the thing
um but anyway turns out a couple months
into the thing she was
crazy seven shades of nuts
bear macadamia brazil nut
peanuts cashew cashew fam pistachio
she was cronkers
um [ __ ] nuts so anyway things had to
give but i
couldn't get enough of her family like
literally but the thing is as well i
think this is important
i was only into this girl because i
found her so attractive
but there's obviously a person i sucked
a person when she wasn't having a crazy
face a personality didn't suck yeah it
was all right yeah
but like when
she was on one of her
things like examples like there was one
time
we were walking to the shop together and
i randomly got a phone call
i was talking to the person and i was
like yo i gotta go i gotta go
i didn't say oh i gotta go because i'm
with xyz i just said oh i'm busy i'll go
go i came off the phone and she was off
of me
for literally two days off of me didn't
speak to me wouldn't reply to my text
nothing for two days
and then finally i said what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you cause like
we're together we're fine like
everything's blessed like what's going
on like why
why are you not talking to me and she
said oh you think i'm stupid
i'm not slack hang on
[Laughter]
hang on what do you mean women
jump to conclusions she lets
do you remember those toys you get in
kinder eggs the little
the little frog and you flick its back
and it flies the little plastic frog you
flick it and it goes
that's what she did she was one of them
man oh
she's one of them little bugs that
skates on water you seen them thinking
on ponds
she's she lept so she was like you think
i'm stupid
and i was like what
where are we in this conversation what's
going on she was like
obviously you're on the phone to another
girl you didn't want her to know that
you're with me
so i'm assuming she's your girlfriend
so you you quickly got off the phone
because i was there
and i was like and you came to this
conclusion
when and how like what happened yeah
she couldn't obviously couldn't explain
herself she was like oh you're all
talking about i'm busy i'm busy i gotta
go like why would you not stay on the
phone just because i'm there
and i'm like because i mean i'm in your
company yes
it's us moment it's us we're shopping
i'm trying to be romance
we're shopping for food for dinner that
i'm gonna cook for you guys i'm trying
to cook linguine
and i'm i'm trying to be this there it
is
i want this i want this bottle
she's left and you're out here assuming
the worst of me
i was like yo family you for real are
you for real
nah cause so that was just one of the
moments
we've i've spoken about her before so
you you long time has remained remember
her as the girl that
launched stuff out the window that i
bought her thinking
my car was down there so she could smash
up she was clapped
um she was beautiful she was banging and
then yeah this [ __ ]
when he's working in a restaurant
decided to recommend her for a job
she asked me because me the thing is you
men were boys me and her had a
relationship because they had a
relationship so i was like
default but we were actually very cool
with each other and we kind of stayed in
touch
after uni but they didn't because they
ended sour
and that's just a fact they understand
i'm sour so
i was working and she was she's
obviously younger than me or she's
younger than us
and she she said i think for a summer
break she needed a job
i was like boom okay i'll see you we're
hiring and then i planned it for her she
didn't last long
but i think she was shooting for a
couple of months or something but yeah
she was there she never lasted long in
jobs
she had too much she thought she was the
yeah she had too much ego she had bagel
i can see why because she's banging
banging
but um i hope she does [ __ ] now anyway
[ __ ] her um
but yeah yeah i didn't know how i got
into this topic oh my
man i forgot my man even existed i
forgot my man even said the thing
yeah firm is tough because he only let
he got over it or he
he dealt with it because he had to leave
the situation
i went to another city and it was that
moved like 100 miles away and it was
done
it was not because of her but it was
circumstances it was circumstances it
was done
that was it um so yeah i'm sorry because
you're stuck
unless you move location you're stuck no
real advice i feel like um the only
thing you can
do is either you can you've got two
options i haven't drowned yourself in
other [ __ ]
so you forget about her that won't work
i know yeah
i have that's what i said there's two
options i ever drowned yourself another
[ __ ]
um so you can take your mind off her or
actively look for something else or
someone else like
actively try and i don't know take your
mind like do something to take your mind
off stuff
yeah i find an activity to do yeah find
find something something i found
which has actually helped me in most
recent years and this isn't
to get over people or something like
that but it's just what it does
for the clarity of your brain yeah is it
actually get into hobbies
and i know you're not looking for that
like obviously you messaged her you
messaged us
sorry talking about yo this girl's toxic
i want to get over
how can i do that and i'm coming at you
like start karate
go go to a yoga lesson like but it's for
real when you when you embed yourself
in something that actually absorbs your
entity like you you
really have to try to be good at this
yeah
and there's a steep learning curve when
you when you put yourself in those kind
of situations
not only does it distract your mind but
it also gives you
clarity about what's important we're
still going to drink these later
yeah yeah yeah just so it doesn't get
warm
it gives you clarity of what is
important in your life
because when you obsess about something
so for example right
this same girl there was an occasion
right there was an occasion where we
were
not out so this was this this was you
understand this is me
this is me and b okay so there was a
time where me and fuhrer were out on a
night out
in this club and this is when you may
have heard us refer to this before this
was when i was in my peak
this was in monday james era this was
alexander the great this was julius
caesar like i was
crushing on like there's nothing
tomorrow so basically obviously this is
the time where i was seeing this go but
i was actually still in my
optimum curve so if i wanted new [ __ ]
it was easy so we were in a time we won
a break or whatever she was going
through one of her crazy phases and um
she took the time to tell me about
another guy that tried to talk to her
and she was talking this is how you know
she was no good for me family yeah like
when you listen to this you're like
it sounds familiar she was talking about
like oh
this guy he tried to chat to me the
other day he was beautiful he was like
6'4
light-skinned beautiful curls
green eyes muscular all of this and
obviously
your boy now is jacked like i'm i'm
massive
but at the time i wasn't such yeah
at the time i didn't have these guns you
gave me so anyway moving on moving on
let's not dwell on me um so
she's she's pouring on she's telling me
about how much she loves it love not
loves this guy but
like oh they exchanged numbers and all
this with that and i'm like
big man what you telling me
to be i was like why are you trying to
hurt i'm in love with you what are you
doing tonight i love you
i love you why would you say this
i was upset and i'm like big man we'll
scan on you yeah
yeah why are you doing this to me that's
so funny and i was upset because i bet
obviously actually saying i'm picturing
a picture
and in my head he's me times four
he's buff and i was livid
i was thinking such a human can't exist
surely such a human can't exist and move
to my
goal oh lord lord
save me save me from this heartache man
said take me
take me she's down so
she's pouring on and i'm thinking this
[ __ ]
so anyway she's saying this guy this guy
we're gonna go on a date we're gonna do
this
do that and i'm like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah so
me and fred's gonna night out one night
and she comes out
and i say she's looking piff obviously
and i'm thinking you know what
she's she's certified that we're done
she's talking about i like this guy
we're talking we're texting all this
stuff
so obviously we're done so
um this other thing
that had body
deep voice body amg
thing s line
lamborghini bent matte black
she moved to me on the spot and i was
like calm
i don't care if b is in the thing i
don't care
she's she thinks she can come to me
talking about this and that all this
toxic [ __ ]
that i don't need in my soul i'm gonna
let this girl
have her way so she starts dancing on me
in the in the forbidden sense
she's dancing do we do the forbidden
salsa
[Laughter]
we got dusty we go nasty
so my days she sees it and she
kicks the [ __ ] off goes ballistic
do you remember she walked out the thing
and i needed you i was like chase that
i hollered you on a bat signal and i was
like fam
help me that's how you know i'm your
friend
fam that's how you know i'm your friend
listen listen listen listen back then
that was the first time not the first
time but that was the real real time
that i was like who had is riding for me
as a friend
i've never like he's doing he's doing
business that like
i wouldn't do like if you [ __ ] up
and you tell me to sort out you're
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] off i'm busy drinking and
boogieing
i've got a thing here i've got a thing
on my lap i'm not chasing anyone
let alone your girl because you're
[ __ ] another girl
what's going on anyway you rode for me
cause
so you chased after her
said yo he didn't mean it like all these
things
and man said he didn't mean it
like say he wasn't actively so she fell
on me
so we were like yeah we were doing the
forbidden dance
and then um yes obviously you you went
after all this stuff
yeah and she made me feel like the bad
guy yeah yeah yeah like
none of what she said was valid yeah so
anyway that's how toxic this girl was
um so like it it took for me
listen like after this this is how bad
this girl was
after this she made me feel like i had
desperately [ __ ] up i was in my room
on youtube listening to
poetry poetry for time
yeah and i was thinking oh this
resonates these might have been through
the heartache i'm going through
these men have been through it wow
and then eventually we patch things up
because of you as well again
i don't remember because i was texting
my girl's phone off
like yo please just chat to me
understand the thing
if you can understand the situation you
understand
where my head was at all these things
and she was airing me erin
and you went to work and she happened to
be there yeah
no that's it she worked at the same spot
that you worked at yeah
and you man had a team meeting yeah so
you went
you you rode for me you saw what you
sold on my
case and then you text me you text me
and you were like fam she's gonna hear
you out
be here in five minutes
be here in five minutes ran out of the
yard
i was in my boxes eating ice cream at
the top
i was embedded jerry's at the box and
you said be there
five fam i coco'd my
entity bare coca bottle deodorant
grease in the hair everything eyebrows
slicked
gums the freshest gums i could find
cardigan
luckily i was driving like then yeah
luckily i bought my car that year i scur
scared down the road and i dipped in
there
and she was leaving as i walked in i
told her
we had this thing listen listen listen
oh god
we had this thing we were heated
we were heated and she was like big man
like why
are you even about yeah like why are you
even trying so hard and i
nearly told her that i loved her yeah at
the time i listened guys i was young i
was naive
yeah i nearly told her that i loved it
this is
the most cliche thing you've ever heard
and i was like
she was like why are you trying so hard
take the [ __ ] hint like i'm not
answering your text
i'm not answering your calls why are you
still trying yeah
and i was like because i love
iq cause and she was like what and i was
like
i like you
obviously because she's a yeah yeah she
got sentimental with the thing
she was like man loves me we went to
asda the same night
we have a dance
we went as a 11 pm held hands it was
calm panned
but she was toxic and that was one
occasion
that was one occasion of about 10.
fifteen
more [ __ ] she knew she was toxic and i
rode for you
you wrote for me she was busting down
our door
flipping my mattresses this is the same
[ __ ] this is the same thing
my football days were fist anyway like
obviously this is the same hoe that was
doing all this madness and
i knew she was evil for me but like i
i couldn't give her up yeah i
started about i couldn't give her up so
yeah the only way i got out of it was i
left but at the end of the day
like sorry as i was saying half an hour
ago
if you get yourself invested in
something that is bigger than you
so for me this has only happened to me
in the last couple years but it was
jujitsu so
i may have mentioned it a long long time
ago i haven't done it since covered it
but jujitsu for me was like it's like
chess like it's something that
it completely it's like learning the
language yeah it's com
it completely absorbs your mind and
absorbs your time
yeah and you realize like right there's
bigger that there's bigger
it's just there's so much more it gives
you so much perspective yeah
it gives you something that's like this
is something that people have spent
decades yeah trying to put trying to
perfect yeah and i'm
here sweating over one yeah they're a
man willing to give up
all their time all the effort just to
to perfect the art of this grappling
style yeah and i'm here sweating over
some [ __ ] that's sucking off
all demanding
what time is it because it's clearly not
my time
you get me i'm how am i sweating over
this hole and these men are
are practicing bonkers things so
perspective yeah it gives you
perspective so at the end of the day
to round up this long rant
put yourself in a position where you can
you can find something start a hobby
that you realize
fact it can be origami yeah jujitsu
karate it can be [ __ ]
going to the gym it can be learning
arabic
it could be starting islam you give me
anything that's bigger than you yeah
once you start something that's bigger
than you you
you gives you such perspective that
you're acting like a nut case
yeah and you haven't got the time for it
anymore you haven't got
fam you haven't got the time for it yeah
you just realize like what i can be an
idiot
like let's just lock you you found i
give it two weeks you'll lock her off
yeah once your mind
is all it it sucks but you realize that
it's not
love cause it's just all in your head
you're infatuated with this thing and
you realize you can be just as
infatuated with the anatomy object as
you can with this hoe
yeah i can be just as infatuated with
learning jujitsu
as i can with this [ __ ] biho yeah
that was
constantly in your head in my head if i
would have just poured my efforts into
something
more dynamic more tangible more tangible
more educated more beneficial
self-sufficient
self-sufficient i would have forgot
about her in an instant
but i didn't and that's why she ruined
my life for a year plus
so yeah man hopefully you take that
advice i hope you know i genuinely
recently thing is as well it's not it's
no games i genuinely hope you take
this advice like i don't give good
advice
we don't give a good advice sometimes
and it's all jokes and it's all shits
and gigs by the end of the day
i genuinely think i hope you take this
advice because trust me fam
i've been through it yeah and it's all
fun and games thinking
how do i get rid of her and all this fam
i've been through it
you've been i won't
let's not let's not you've who has
been through it he didn't know when to
drop oh
anyway it's not healthy
it's not healthy you can't do anything
else you can't think of any you can't
think or do you can't breathe without
thinking about her
[ __ ] you can't you can't breathe
without thinking everything reminds you
of her
what sort of movie that me and toby love
uh 500 days of summer that's a great
movie
fantastic movie joseph gordon lever
should have got the oscar for that movie
fantastic movie you did that on one of
your old things one of my old teams yeah
casually yeah don't watch that
youtube don't watch that i'll let one
day i'm going to let it drop
i don't remember that it'll be a patreon
offs yeah pay for that i'll pay for that
um but yeah josie gordon left 500 days
of summer fam like he can't get
off this [ __ ] and she's nothing but
poison
um but yeah man just
give yourself this is a thing as well
this is this is something that
um this is going on but manner
this is something that i understand you
know when people give themselves up to
god
yeah and they get really interesting
this is this is this is the premise
of born again christians yeah do you
understand yeah when people cut they
find jesus later in life
yeah it's more about something to me
personally because i'm i'm an atheist
i don't really believe in god like that
sometimes i really do believe in a
higher being and sometimes i really do
believe in like this can't just be loved
yeah yeah yeah like sometimes i do but
sometimes i'm just like whatever
you know i mean yeah it sounds horrible
if you're religious i'm sorry if i've
ended you but like sometimes i'm just
like
whatever i mean i'll just be on my mind
but like
when i find people some sometimes this
is my perspective when
when i see people when they say i found
jesus like i found the lord yeah and all
this stuff
i feel it really really resonates with
what we just said yeah
they found something that's more
important than their own
[ __ ] [ __ ] than everything all the
[ __ ] around them
and they can see other people that have
dedicated
time effort lifespan to the
to this this one thing this one object
this one
being this one like this one opportunity
like this one mindset yeah they've given
their everything to it and
um that's what they find just
just acknowledging that that this is a
thing
yeah just absorbs them of all
all the negativity in their life and for
a lot of people
if it's spiritual yeah so they feel like
ra
i found god like i found jesus like
from the way i felt when i found
jiu-jitsu it sounds dumb but like the
way i felt when i found jujutsu
if someone told me yo this is a religion
yeah
sign me up sign me up
because i know what you mean people
underestimate the
the power of education yeah because like
when it's a serious education and i'm
talking decades of
investment yeah when there's more to
learn than you think you can ever learn
in a lifetime
it feels like
unequivocal yeah you know i mean it
feels like you would never grasp
the whole thing so it might it feels
inhuman because it feels like
i'll never understand this entirely yeah
and like um there's people that i've
fought in judicial stuff
for example okay for context because
they i've said to jesus like nine times
if humans aren't aware i study like
brazilian jiu jitsu so brazilian jiu
jitsu is like a grappling form grappling
being like wrestling so no striking or
punching or kicking
like wrestling if you see if you get
into it for a bit it's literally like
playing chess
and to the point where someone who is
half my size
can beat my ass if they know jiu-jitsu
better than i can
yeah when you experience it in reality
when you experience a child like i'm
talking i've fought
gal yeah that are 45 kilograms
murk me yeah like put me in a position
where i don't know what to do
yeah like
in my opinion that's this is very
blasphemous and i apologize if you're a
quite religious person
in my opinion this is the is equivalent
to seeing god
okay experiencing god yeah because you
you physically can't comprehend
how this is possible yeah because in any
other given day or moment i'm obviously
going to knock you the [ __ ] out guys
exactly yeah
exactly and then like we said like in
other episodes and stuff like the
patreon episode
we did we say like obviously like when
we talk about rape culture and stuff
like that
is it's obvious that a man can overpower
a woman
especially if there's a severe weight
disparity yeah
it's like i don't need to talk about it
it's obvious so when um
when you do jujitsu and someone who's so
much smaller than you
so much more feeble will twist you up
from choke you unconscious
and you're trying your best like that's
the thing you're trying the best you can
possibly try
it's like it's like experiencing
something
cosmic [ __ ] and you're like this is
impossible
yeah that's what i'm saying like stuff
like this like it obviously
isn't a religion so you understand it
for just an art form you're like cool
you just move but i can understand when
people
feel like they've found god yeah it's
something similar to this
okay because they're like this is
something i can't comprehend this is
something bigger than me
yeah and i can see why such a large
population
invest their life into this yeah and it
frees you from so much
it frees you from fear it feels you from
inhibitions it frees you from so much
because you're just like
how can i be stressed about this when
there's man that there's just yeah it's
that half my size twisting me up yeah
i can express stress about bills when
there's a there's a hoe that can choke
me out with her legs
it doesn't make sense and i'm just
sweating about council tax
i'll be sweating about this yet that
sucks off all my boys
and has me jumping through hoops so
again to wrap it up
fam get into something do some doodles
do something do anything that is is a
significant the the the key part is a
significant time investment yeah of
course that's
yeah it can't be just put something
really really
into it that you're passionate about
yeah it's a big learning curve yeah
something like this start podcast
that's the first thing i thought about
fam write a diary start podcast do
anything
our youtube channel something that's
really really really going to take your
mind off of it
and i promise you give it six days and
you will forget all about and you'll be
embarrassed
that you even have to message us yeah
because but i know what it feels like to
be
deep deep deep in the blue season and so
do i and you can't see the surface you
can't
you think this is never gonna end this
is the love of my life yeah i don't know
how to get over her
you actually think it's one of them ones
where you actually see stuff like
remember that girl you couldn't live
without where is she now
where is she now mom i at the time i
genuinely believed that me and b were
going to get married yeah that time is a
healer
time is a healer just invest your time
into something and i promise you from
six days done
you'll forget about her and generally
you thought me and that girl were going
to get married as well oh i know you did
oh i know you did i was in it but anyway
let's wrap up let's wrap up yeah this
wrapper has a long episode
i don't think i'm ever going to get in
yeah all right i love you guys see you
later next week